good morning everyone so we are starting
with this keynote I think that the title
of the keynote changed fans ask maybe
maybe it's possible it's possible but we
offer a presenter that I really
appreciate because I've been in working
in supercomputing for some time and he
had one idea that now it is quite common
which is disturbing processors
processors are looking for food to be
fed and now everyone at today agrees
with him but he had that idea some time
ago I mean it's not my idea i mean i am
convinced that vendors already realized
that like 20 years ago right as i said
that in general people is not aware of
this of this issue and i started talking
about about this maybe sixty six years
ago seven years ago after developing six
years is like the age of the universe so
please welcome Francis called Ted that
will talk about how many computer trends
you like us so thank you very much it's
a great pleasure to be here thanks for
the renovation for inviting me for
giving this ski note it's nice to see so
many people attending this kind of
conferences i remember in 2002 in the
first european conference in cali ryan
belgium i think we were like 100 more or
less all from the older parts of europe
and nowadays 14 years later we have more
people registered in this confidence
than 14 years ago so it's it's nice this
says a word about the hobby brand is is
the Python community so I am a freelance
consultant I am ready to
to tackle to help people in projects and
I will start by cycling a quote by Isaac
Asimov when I was teenager I read a lot
of books by Isaac Asimov especially is
scifi books not only sci-fi but but I
especially like it sci fi books and he
was really a very good writer very
intelligent man and he was asked many
times why he was so interested in sci-fi
and one of his answers was really
interesting for me so he said that
realizing the future in particular he
said that no sensible decision can be
made any longer without taking in
account not only the world as it is but
the world as it will be some sci-fi for
him was very interesting for projecting
the attendances and then taking measures
in in advance for the phone to to these
tendencies so duly marked olk i would
like to convince you that not sensible
in the same way no sensible decision can
be made any longer without taking a
night into account not only the computer
as it is by the computer as it will be
it's very important so let's let me say
a few words about me a young physicist
by training computer scientist by
passion and also on open-source
enthusiasts okay I am my first serious
project was pie tables which is now it's
quite used because it's one of the back
ends of pandas for sale Allison data is
quite powerful and we'll say a few words
about it but right now my main projects
are a blog which is a high-performance
compressor and then also because which
is a data container that can deliver
this box as well why i am doing open
source projects well
I think a programmer heavily programmer
and that means every one of you has an
artist inside okay programming is a lot
about art it's not only about technique
and you know when you have when you are
doing art you are full of ideas and but
it happens that sometimes realizing
these ideas is not easy right but it's
absolutely necessary and in fact as
manual ultracet the art is in the
execution of the idea not in the idea
itself because not much left is there is
not much left just from an idea and of
course real artist also needs to ship
needs to offer this ideas the position
of these ideas to the pole to the public
in general so for me open source is a
nice way to realize yourself while you
are helping our apps you are giving part
of your time to the community okay and
giving your time giving your love it's
important pi tables watch my project
like for nine years it's a long time my
tables is a rapper Python wrapper for
hdf5 but it's not just a wrapper but
implements different capabilities that
are not inside hdf5 itself so for
example it implements like queries
indexed queries and when I started
experimenting with indexing in the past
decade and also I got interested in in
implementing out of correlations that
means that when you have a race in
memory and it doesn't fit in memory you
need to start visualizing on disk and
you should be able to do an execute to
the operations on decent race so I
implemented that in in PI tables as well
and this is this quite quite useful but
most importantly is also started
experimenting with with compression
so I really got very interested in
compression while I was working with
with buy tables so let's go to the real
meat of the of the of the talk I'm going
to talk about present trends in computer
architecture also why we need the speed
everyone needs a speed but especially in
storing and processing as much data as
possible using your existing resources
and at the end i will talk a little bit
about blocks and because as just as
examples of compressor and the
containers that leverages the principles
of newer computer architectures ok let's
go with some trends in computer storage
in the past decade or maybe more than
one decade we have seen that the the gap
between the arm speed and the hard disk
is large and it's increasing bitte bitte
ok in this in this period the vendors
have introduced nic-10 new technologies
that fit between the hard disks and
memory ok this technology is called SSDs
ok solid state disks so let aesthetics
now are very common almost every one of
you will have one of these in your
laptops they started like just a
replacement of the of the hard disks
using the same buses ok then the hard
disks but recently vendors realized that
these buses became a bottleneck as well
and they are implemented implementing
SSDs on top of PCI Express right which
removes this vast limitation but
bandwidth limitation and present friends
are that they are making this device is
a smaller and smaller ok this is really
meant for laptop for example and this is
the newest incarnation of SSDs
that this this is the size of an SD card
so this is really really small and that
means that you will be able to have
access this just in your iphones or in
your smart function ok and the
interesting thing is that this SS this
very small as this will also have PCI
Express bus so that means with these
very small devices you will have
extremely fast data storage and my
opinion the new applications should be
able to leverage all this technology
especially SSDs with PCI also when you
are designing new software new
applications you not be aware of Latin
seas ok what it says is the time that it
takes between that the processor ask for
a some data and the time that the data
starts to flow to the processor ok and
that is a very important issue as Chief
Jeff Dean and Peter Norvig from google
realized several years ago so in their
opinion every programmer that is meant
to deal with with IO should be aware of
the different latencies ok interesting
thing for me about this is that when the
cpu ask for some data we are calling
this the trf with the trf is the time
that in reference for the photo
reference is the time that passes
between the the request for some data
until the request the the device that is
for example starts to transfer to
actually transfer the data ok because
there is a latency time for getting for
the storage to getting ready in order to
serve transmitting that and of course we
have we need to optimize that by making
this
these times at least very close okay
because if the transmission time is much
more if it's much more is lower than the
reference time the latency dime we're
wasting time most of the time is spent
okay by the by the storage preparing
data to be sent and thus that has
implications of how we should access the
media storage media okay so for example
for memory the latency times the typical
latency times are 100 nanoseconds this
is the typical one and for the typical
speeds it's that means that we we are
able to transmit to one kilobyte in this
time okay for solid state disks this
optimal blog is four kilobytes okay and
for hard disks this were around one
megabyte so that means that as the
slower the media the larger the block it
is worth the transfer okay but the most
important thing is that we want to get
best performance that means that we
should access over they take a blocked
way okay this is extremely important
independently of the media that you are
using if this memory disk or whatever or
network okay so we need we absolutely
need more data blocking infant universe
infrastructure in my opinion and
unfortunately not many data containers
focus on blocking access okay of course
we are not going to get a civil war a
civil bullet and we won't be able to
find a single container that makes
everyone happy okay every data container
it is non pie it is none it is pandas it
is because whatever they will have all
will have their drawbacks and they will
excel in something it's all about
trade-offs and what important thing is
that with block access we can you
ated persistent media like disks or as
it is a female and the other way around
so if we use blood access we get some
kind of Independence of the media and
that that's also a very important thing
that we should be aware of okay so let's
put this question okay we know that we
can get better performance but you seen
assess this but we can put this question
can we get better bandwidth than the
hardware allows it seems like a
contradiction in itself oh let's see so
for example this our fact sheet of a
performance eat out of the solid state
this Intel solid state drive 520 series
okay and these devices and lately most
of the solid state disks use compression
internally although you are not aware of
that okay and when you use when you
disable the compressor in the driver of
the other hard disk you see this this
this performance okay so for example for
sequential right you get 255 but by
using compressible data you can get up
to 520 okay so that's a nice improvement
that compression allows us to but not
this is not not touching would always
work because for read for grillin we had
we have no improvement okay and when you
wait when we are doing random right and
Brandon rate we have similar behavior
okay for writing we are accelerating a
lot not for reading anyone I am going to
put your question the first kiss squeeze
anyone knows why there is this magic
number here that we cannot pass like 100
five hundred and fifty megabytes per
second why there is no improvement in
this in this area anyone has a hint this
is a magic number yeah exactly this is a
solid estate dial a disk that is
attached to the SATA 2 bus sata2 bus as
a memory bandwidth limitation of 500
megabytes per second which is exactly
what we are seeing here so although we
could be able to get more performance
well invited by the bus in this case how
it's how we can get rid of this
limitation my opinion a much better
strategy is not to trust in compression
in the same device but use compression
at the CPU level so let's see if we can
store the data in a compressed State on
this okay we need to transmit less
information than we if we need to
transfer all the data in a compressed
State okay of course we have an overhead
because we need to decompress this data
in order to this to the CPU to be able
to play with it the thing is if you sum
these two times the transmission time
and the compression time and these times
are less than the time that it takes to
transmit all the compressed it into the
CPU we're actually getting more
performance right we can we can fit the
cpu with more data per second than using
and compression the only thing that we
need is that this overhead here is not
too much with the only thing so what's
the state of the technology for that the
CPS will will be able to decompress that
fast enough this are this is a plot that
I got like six years ago when I was
elementum with blog and pay tables this
is the performance they perceived
performance of of the throughput and we
we see that by using different kinds of
compressors in green we have said lip
and said lip is the compression behind
Jessup which is quite quite common and
in red this is LC tall which was one of
the fastest compressor at the time when
I was before I started working on block
and we see that these two compressors
were all really able to get better
performance out of hard disk this was a
hard disk using a SATA regular chat i
think the the bamboo it was 150 or 200
something like that and we we have seen
i saw that i was able to get better
performance but i wanted to push the
performance at maximum and by using
blows i was able to get much better
performance than that so by using blogs
and eat the data is compressible enough
of course ok i was kind of doing tricks
because this is really really
compressible data but my main idea was
by saying hey the compressors can get
the meat can be used to get much much
better performance out of optics so now
let's put another question how to get
maximum compression performance because
we know that getting matching
performance commission performance is
going to allow us not to store more data
using the same resources but also in
many tie in many cases to accelerate our
computations especially if they are out
of core and for that we need to
understand the recent trends on
devolution of cpus ok
I've seen this plot first time like 10
years ago maybe and this part is really
interesting because it shows the
evolution of the cpu speed in green ups
and in red devolution of the memory
speed and we can see that through the
time we win we see we have seen a gap
which is white and opening and there is
no signs that is god this is going to
stop okay so that means that 20 years
ago or 30 years ago when the cpu asked
for some data min memory he was able to
get the response in this in the next
clock cycle of the cpu this is not the
case in any anymore right now the CPUs
have to wait more than 100 cycles before
they actually get the response and this
is this is extremely important to be
aware of okay so we need to fight about
I call I like to call this the CPU
starvation problem because most of the
time when our mother superiors are a
starving for data they need data in red
to process then the problem is so
apparent vendors realized I'd clearly
right and in the past decade or two
decades they were adding level cache
levels in this abuse just to palliate
this this this gap okay and nowadays in
this decade having this here keep memory
hierarchy is quite common okay having
mechanical the solid state disks main
memory and up to three levels of cache
an educated guess is that in the future
this here is going to be much more
complex okay and in might this is a
little bit a projection on myself
think it's a quite educated guess and we
will we will see nine levels of of
memory okay in the hierarchy this X
point thing is the initiative that is
led by Intel and micro for having memory
which behaves very close to run but that
is persistent okay and it fits right
between the SSD pci and run in terms of
a spittin and latin see and you know / i
mean this this sort of things is not
exactly common but if we use the
blocking technique as I explained before
we have changed these chances and
defining the block size depending on the
on the memory level that you are it's
important will be more and more
important to get better performance more
for common threads trends so the CPUs
are getting more and more course inside
of the same die presently intel
announced taxi asean we with i think is
24 course which is really a big number
okay sometimes getting all the all of
them working for you it's such a
challenge then another trend is that CP
modern CPUs has a special much card
special hardware a special hardware
special machinery for for doing vector
operations and they are increasing the
size of the bus of this of this simple
instruction multiple data hard work and
leveraging this is really really
important not many applications do that
but the hardware s is there for ages I
mean ages in computer science a scheme
set is like 20 years or less than that
and finally we have seen CPU plus a GPU
integration both AMD and Intel are
integrating GPUs inside the same design
recibimos and not many software is
taking library is leveraging this
disintegration as well ok so the
compressor the buss compressor is using
these new advances in competing in CPUs
that not many others are using right in
particular it uses it is multi-threaded
so it uses many cards multicore
sufficiently it also uses SAS I and D in
order to do transformations before the
compulsion stage right in order to allow
the competitor to go faster ok and the
only thing that it doesn't use currently
is the is the GPU ok but probably the
next version of Lusk should be able to
use the GPU as well and that allows I
think that many people is quite accept a
skeptical about it right with that block
is able to easily beat many times the
speed of a memory memory to memory copy
ok the mem cpy system goal just by using
more threads and by using SI and the
acceleration for me there is nothing
wrong on that memory is like a storage
media ok and we are using tricks to
compress that and transmit this
information into the cashiers so we are
making less information to the caches ok
so this is perfectly possible but also
with with high complications so we have
seen that we can we can improve ramming
speed so in the same way that we were
improving the speed of reading disc
memories another memory layer right
so the only thing is that we need to
make the compressor fast enough and we
can we have seen that blood is able to
accelerate memory performance not in all
cases but in many cases and my
projection is that this will be
happening more and more in the future
okay and in fact the vendors are
realizing that intel has just
implemented compression in hardware to
get to compress textures and to bring
textures in a compressed instead from
ram into into the cpu into the GPU that
is integrated in the cpu okay my opinion
is that however the compression is nice
because it's fast but it's not as
flexible as forward compression here we
have an example for those that came to
my to my workshop on come friday about a
real data real data set we see that
because which is one complete one data
container that you splash behind the
scenes it can get better performance
viewed by using the data the data
contained in a compressed a state that
if we are not using in the compressor
state okay this is a clear demonstration
of that and this is the time that I
expand us that is doing the query on on
disk on memory sorry and the nice thing
about because we will see is that it
will it allows the Tekken ties to be not
only memory but also on disk and the API
exactly the same so for because memory
is exactly the same the same media than
disk but with different properties with
different lattices and different block
sizes this has not been always the case
for example using a another laptop we
see that we have still the other head in
compression okay so anywhere University
use we
we are already seeing the speed land and
of course the other important thing of
compressed containers is that they allow
us to spend less resources for tackling
the same data or setting in other words
with the same resources you can handle
much more data so blood is meant not to
accelerate things from the mechanical
list to the CPU but it's especially
meant for tackling accelerating the the
the performance between the solid state
disk and also main memory to the CPU you
have not to take my word of it I mean
independent people has tested many
different compressors and they are very
pleased about block performance okay
then that means also that people in
general is becoming more and more
interested in compression for a reason
now in the last part of my talk I'm
going to explain the the principles of
because about why because allows so much
speed is not only about using
compression you need more forgetting
forgetting that this is what I premised
for the people who attended to my
workshop that I will I was going to
explain the principles don't why be
cautious so fast so what's because
because provides little containers that
can be used in a similar way than non pi
abundance they can be indexed the same
way they can be sliced they can be you
can die and as lies as as much as you
want the main difference is that data
storage is change is not contiguous and
it sank just because it is blocked and I
said before blocking is the essence of
doing that of doing operations if we
want to improve
I oh it comes with two flavors see array
which is meant to a store to host
homogeneous and dimensional it about
data types and also see table which is
meant for a TD genotypes in a culinary
state in a colon driveway so here is the
difference between contiguous and chant
for example moonpies an example of
continuous data container and that means
that when you define an array in Mumbai
you have a block of memory which is
which is continuous right here in CRA in
because we split the different DK Arya
in blocks they are called chunks okay
because the blocks are I mean every tank
is the faster as a block inside I don't
go to the to enter into the details
because they can be very complex but I
just want you to get the idea everything
is changed here and the interesting
thing is that you can compress
individually every tank and when you
need this chanc this thing will be
transmitted in a compressed istituto the
caches will be the compressed in the
cache and you will be able to operate on
with that okay also I said that the seat
table the diligence container is column
why columnar just because it had that's
better to newer computer architectures
why right now if we have a row wise
table so for example instructor at
mumbai array if we are interested in
just one single column like this one
here the system that we texture of newer
systems when whenever you touch this
integer32 which is four bytes that the
hardware is not grabbing only only four
bytes but the hardware is grabbing this
the next 64 bytes in five minutes okay
time time flies
it transmits all the 64 bytes and that
means if we are handling only this the
condition for example on this on this
column we can see that we get instead of
getting four bytes per but element we
are getting 64 bytes which is called the
cache line and that means what that we
are wasting out of resources because the
bandwidth is waste right well as we
store data in a columnar way okay we are
getting exactly they said that the data
we need that we need into the CPU okay
because the contiguous the continuous
data is here okay also of as we group
data that has similar properties there
is much less entropy between element to
element in the same column and that
means much better compressions so for
recalls it is very very important to
have column not approach here we see
some project using be calls so visual
fabric which is a company that we have
several people working for for this
company is using because through a new
software on top of pickles which is
called bigquery which is basically to to
allow out of core group buys also the
psyche it ll which is using genomics is
using because with a lot of success and
con top ian is also using because X very
extensively in the infrastructure so
this is big query in action it is able
to do group buys out of core in a and
this slow down with with respect to
pandas it's just a factor of three or
four more than pandas but this is doing
that all in memory whereas bigquery is
doing that on disk and the slaughter is
just between two and four it's a big win
for them they don't have to spend a lot
of
money on on aura SSDs are much cheaper
alastair males miles which is the main
offer of psyche ll it's also very
pleased with because you race and let me
have three minutes for explaining the
new features of plus 2 which is will be
the next version of blush blush of
course has limitations one of the main
limitations in my opinion is that it
needs to operate with chank chank system
is a higher level after level of
abstraction in gloves too I am
implemented a new level of abstraction
that will allow several chance to be
grouped in what I call a super challenge
why I am doing that well that has a lot
of advantages one of them is that it
will be able to for blush to look into
the redundancies between defendant
chance ok the same way die mmm back to
for example between different frames and
then also in in plus 2 we will have
multiple for products that in particular
set SD stds at the standard which is
made by the same alpha of LCD for which
is one of the best compressors fastest
compressors now and also it will support
a civilized version of the super tank
and that means that you can store much
more chance using less resources less I
note ok because you are packing several
chunks in one single inode in the
independence is that's important you
will have support for i erm erm
architecture will be a first citizen
launching balls too and of course plus
two it's still being developed this is
still in beta and alpha ok i am not
going to mess anything with blush blush
too is developed in a completely
separate repository and you are invited
to test them and help me in debugging it
or or even helping me to develop it
giving your time giving you off
okay so the main point is that due to
devolution in computer architecture the
completion can be effective for two
reasons first we can work with more data
with the same resources and also and
especially that we can reduce the
overhead of compression to near zero
right due to evolution of the CPUs and
if we know how to use the CPUs but not
only near zero but beyond that and that
means that by using compression we can
get better performance when I will I
will finish with a sentence of marvin
minsky which is the one of the pioneers
in artificial intelligence he passed
away three months ago in like that and
he said that in science one can learn
the most by students studying what seems
the list anything that that's the case
in when I got interested in compression
at the beginning was like a very very
tiny thing and in my opinion compression
will be a very very important subject
not in the future but is becoming a very
very important subject now gracias
we had time thanks for the fans ask we
have a time for a maybe color of
questions while we're changing laptops
dhaka questions
you can ask in Spanish if you are not
fluent enough flew into nothing in
English I'm fluent in English no problem
the rest of all thanks for the talk and
I wanted to ask you about the chunking
procedure yeah how is it better than
having the whole block of memory store
together because I I know that it's
difficult to find a big enough space in
memory but if you chunk the data frame
you won't be able to access the new
impart that fast because it pulled in
another place and exactly when is it was
this is one of the reasons why this
concern over head that's what the
question is why I cannot work with
continuous continuous storage right
instead of zagged one how is it much
better to chunk it than to have a store
together through to tell the truth the
best the most efficient way is to come
everything together because as you said
is much it much more easy to locate the
information that we are interested in
right I have not told you all the
details in the CRA implementation but
the thing is that the CRA has index
index information in the headers right
and he knows where the data is located
in every feather so you have kind of a
intermediate level that you have to go
to the index first but then you can go
that but even with that the advantage of
having the shank compressed is is I mean
is compensating song so to say this
extra level of indirection ok first of
all thank you for your contributions to
the Python ecosystem thank you and I
have many questions bus but just one
what do you think about theater the new
disc format made by West McKinney and
Holly we can I am I have to say that I
am very excited about this new
development I mean feather for those of
you that doesn't know is the new effort
that is
he's been made not only by West makini
but with a lot of by a lot of authors in
the in the are and other arenas for
storing data frames on disk okay this
will represent a standard way to
exchange data between our Python see
whatever and this is really important
the industry needs that because I mean
everyone has cut can't use our Python or
whatever the problem I mean and that
will be very important for for
exchanging data but when you want to get
better performance you will need to use
specific data containers so I see more
feather like a common interface format
more in the similar way hdf5 is a common
interface format then I I storage or a
format that is meant for extreme
performance because I said before there
is no silver bullet okay you will need
different containers for forever
basically depending on your needs but I
am very excited to have a feather I
think it's a very good idea so let's
thank our keynote speaker again
you